hi we're the try guys
[Music]
let's back over there oh he is falling
off of me sex am sitting pretty as Yugi
you want to talk about your package a
beautiful married one is Ned leave a
backup no you're my perfect one right
here Keith everybody gets lost in this
beauty we're so close as friends
yeah each other well enough to know
where the line is yeah and how to just
tiptoe like Ned doesn't like you hit
don't react really there like that guys
stop it we have a new show coming to you
to read called blood wars we're bringing
a bunch of cool fan of squads together
and put them to the challenge each week
they're gonna learn a new skill and at
the end of the day we get to judge them
what's really fun is that each episode
two of us split off and join the squad
so we're not just hosts we get to join
in on the fun we're doing synchronized
swimming what we're doing bullfighting
no we're doing now it'll be great I am
fighting ad yeah we got pro wrestling we
got NASCAR pit crews we got Bollywood
dancing it's just like reality
television but nothing like it at all
find out who nails it
who fails is it squad wars only on
YouTube red can we had an explosion and
an explosion in piano Gazoo that's a rat
oh my god I am so sorry I don't know why
I threw that that was there gonna is it
still work
[Music]